on to looting
not we're not going to do any looting
i'm not going to promise that i mean
once you once you hear about how awesome
it is and important it is
i think you may change your mind i'm not
going gonna do any loading okay fair
enough
i really i actually seriously wish that
people couldn't make this stuff up
because
um you know it's it's really it's cliche
to say you can't make this stuff up but
that's what people are doing people are
making [ __ ] up
and publishing it and then they're
getting interviewed by npr
and npr and other outlets are taking
this seriously and it's becoming
mainstream
and it's it's not nonsense it's not
garbage it is
it is destructive i don't even have the
words
i don't even know what it is it's it's
just destructive
awful i it this borders on evil and
that's not a word i use very much
so here we have um just a minute zach
before you show it an npr
interview with an author of a recently
published book
called i kid you not in defense of
looting
so here we go um
this is um i'm just going to read a
couple of
a couple of a couple of these we'll talk
about and then i want to finish with
what she begins with
so it's this author uh i'll get to vicky
osterwheel
probably mispronouncing her name um
can you talk about rooting wording
looting as a tactic
is the question oh sorry i'm looking for
it i should have had you pull this up
zach
um here we go can you talk about a
rioting as a tactic
what are the reasons people deploy it as
a strategy
so she's not just advocating looting
she's advocating for writing as well
uh she says it does a number of
important things
writing does it gets people what they
need for free immediately which means
that they are capable of living and
reproducing their lives without having
to rely on jobs or a wage which during
covet times is widely unreliable or
particularly in these communities is
often not available
or it comes at great risk that's
looting's most basic tactical powers of
political mode of action
it also attacks the very way in which
food and things are distributed
it attacks the idea of property and it
attacks the idea that in order for
someone to have a roof over their head
or have a meal ticket
they have to work for a boss in order to
buy things that people just like them
somewhere else in the world had to make
under the same conditions
it points to the way in which that's
unjust and for the reason the world is
organized that way
obviously is for the profit of the
people who own the stores and the
factories
so you get to the heart of that property
relation and demonstrate that without
police and without state oppression
we can have things for free are we
are we being punked i can't
i did i did it without laughing you did
but now you are laughing
oh my god yeah it attacks
the idea that in order for someone to
have a roof over the head
oh yeah i even find the most idiotic
stuff in here it's unbelievable
we can just have things for free if we
get rid of the police
and state oppression because how dare
you want to buy something that was made
by someone somewhere else
i just want it for free wait how does
that thing come to
i right what process produces that thing
and why it is so incoherent in every
regard you had some things to say i mean
i have some more oh
i mean no end of things to say i just i
just feel
like um we are being punked
and whatever advanced civilization is
punching us i wish they would stop i
mean maybe they have a lesson to teach
us and they're going to come down in
their ships and they're going to let us
know what that lesson is and we're all
going to
have a big laugh and then we're going to
go to actually governing the planet
properly
do you remember actually during during
the evergreen debacle
one of the chief instigators really
turns out to have been a truly bad actor
but someone who
i had known beforehand uh to be quite
smart
naimolao who one of her things
was performance art and i
said to you at some point early on i
said is it at all possible
that naima is going to show up on some
stage and take a bow
and say i have now shown you what is
possible
i have shown you how i can get a whole
bunch of people to witnessly
follow an insane movement and now you
know
and now you two should wake up to the
the sheep that you
are and actually uh try to do some good
in the world rather than spouting off
rhetoric
now of course she didn't do that instead
she took the college for a bunch of
money and went off to do whatever
the hell she is doing now so you know
alas
she was not playing a giant performance
art
hoax on us but wouldn't that be
wonderful
wouldn't wouldn't that be wonderful if
we were being punked here and they were
about to reveal it could be the next
stanley milgram
yeah exactly it would have been so
powerful actually yeah but i mean i
i don't even like hearing you say this
because the
the role she played was so toxic and
having to just monstrously maintain
even just as a formal possibility that
maybe she was actually
on the right side all along because um
oh it's clear that she wasn't
at this point but you know in the early
days even after she decided that i was a
racist and all the other white women
needed to come and collect my ass and
all of this
i thought it's possible maybe i hope no
yeah yeah no that was wishful thinking
of the highest order yeah
um okay so let's see another
another thing from here during so this
uh
show my screen again zach if you would
during recent riots the interviewer from
npr says
a sentiment i heard a lot was that
looters in cities like minneapolis were
hurting their own cause by destroying
small businesses in their own
neighborhoods
stores owned by immigrants and people of
color what would you say to people who
make that argument
the um the answer
is in part it's long so i'm just going
to read part of it
looters and riders don't attack private
homes they don't attack community
centers
in minneapolis there was a small
independent bookstore that was untouched
all the blocks of reddit were basically
looted or even leveled burned down and
that story just remained untouched
through weeks of rioting
to say you're attacking your own
community is to say to riders you don't
know what you're doing
but i disagree i think people know they
might have worked in those shops they
might have shopped and been followed
around by security
guards by the owner and it goes on and
on and on
so verificationist and actually giving
agency
to the people that many of us would like
to say gosh i hope when you grow up in a
few years you see
what damage what harm you caused and
she's saying no no they know
are they doing the right thing she's
giving them ammunition oh
well no i first of all this has no
or very little implication for the
people actually engaged in this behavior
because the people actually get engaged
in this behavior are motivated by things
other than
uh analysis this is true right i mean
looting in particular
is the you know the system that normally
keeps you from walking out of the store
with the tv is not
functioning so you walk out of the store
of the tv that's what motivates diluting
but a lot of people listen to npr
well that's the thing is it's not the
people this is not targeted at looters
and rioters
this is targeted at people looking for
an excuse
people who have found themselves
confronted with
this isn't a movement about making the
lives of
of black people better look at the
looting and rioting
right look at all those white kids
attacking the federal building
in downtown portland you know what do
you say to somebody who says that and
the answer is well you don't say
anything because frankly it doesn't add
up as part of a movement that's trying
to make
uh the lives of black people better it
adds up as something else in portland
it's anarchism is what it
adds up to so you just need to hand them
an argument and the fact is it doesn't
have to be
a true argument it doesn't have to be a
credible argument it just has to be
something
that allows npr listeners to wave a book
at people and say you know what you're
wrong about looting
right and the fact is like most books
it's not going to get read
and so the idea that somebody has come
up with an argument
and you haven't read it therefore until
you do looting is back on the menu of
of honorable things you know okay i get
it
so we need a name for this category so
if this book whatever it's called in
defense of looting
uh is in this category that you just
described of uh to be used by ammunition
to shut down the people
who have an argument against you robin
deangelo's white fragility is certainly
in that category
as is ibrahim candies how to be an
anti-racist uh
and it would be great if we had a clever
name for that category that we should
that we could invoke whenever we see
more
more books more whatevers that belong in
that category because
while certainly white fragility and how
to be an anti-racist
also serve significant other functions
that they are you know they are
actually indoctrination tools i think
this book is less likely to be that and
more likely just to be something
that you know these you know middle
class liberals who listen to npr
can say oh but don't you see that if you
object to
writing and looting you're actually part
of the problem and you're probably a
white supremacist
yeah the purpose of the book is the
cover yeah right the argument is the
cover the sum total of it
yeah um now i don't know because i
haven't read
uh lindsay and pluck rose yeah i've
done it yep but i'm wondering if this is
not central to their argument
because it seems to be implied on the
cover of their book and i know their
book is full of content because they're
both
um fastidious about these things and uh
so careful such good thinkers
yeah but anyway i'll be curious whether
or not they do have a name for it
and what that name might be yeah
um okay so just two more two more little
bits from this before we
end for today um what would you say to
people
who are concerned about essential places
like grocery stores or pharmacies being
attacked in those communities
zack you probably want to show this
thank you um
and the author says when it comes to
small business family-owned business or
locally owned business
they are no more likely to provide
worker protections they are no more
likely to have to provide good stuff for
the community than big businesses
it's actually a republican myth that has
over the last 20 years really crawled
into even leftist discourse
that the small business owner must be
respected that the small business owner
creates jobs and is part of the
community
that's actually a right-wing myth now
wait a second
didn't the argument above suggest you
don't have to worry about the small
business owners because they're going to
be left alone
yes and then hear the answers so they
don't need to be left-wing i guess you
win either way you win either way that's
the thing with these arguments and the
people who make them
is that they make sure to cover all
their bases completely
uh by doing end runs around their own
arguments and hoping that you aren't
paying attention even from one paragraph
to the next yeah
yes yeah it's uh it's amazing i must say
when i went down
into downtown portland after the rioting
broke out here
one of the first places i encountered
was an
artist cooperative that had had its
window busted in and people had gone
inside and
um didn't look to me i mean the reason i
was struck by it was that it didn't look
like it looked completely indiscriminate
that you would attack
an artist cooperative in portland at the
same time you're attacking the apple
store
yeah no it's there's no there's no rhyme
no reason
and they will keep on telling us that we
aren't looking hard enough for the rhyme
or the reason but no we are
and it's just not there um so one more
one more place to end on uh the very
first question in this interview
uh is for people who haven't read your
book how do you define looting
and i don't actually her definition
isn't that interesting but the second
paragraph of her answer
is looting is a highly racialized word
from its very inception in the english
language
it's taken from hindi lut which means
goods or spoils and it appears in an
english colonial officer's handbook
on indian vocabulary in the 19th century
okay so exactly i have my screen back
thank you what does that even mean um
the claim as far as i understand it
is that uh english having a word from
another language means that that word is
racialized
that's the claim that's the claim even
when the word is actually still being
used in its original meaning
which i looked it up right of course um
it is
like loot loot so um
i went ahead and did some additional
work for for vicki
the author of this book um and the
author of this truly remarkable thought
that uh
lute is a racialized word in english
language because it is in fact borrowed
from the hindi word loot meaning
basically the same thing
meaning loot meaning loot yes uh so i
did some
work for her free of charge i found a
bunch of other highly racialized words
in english all from hindi or urdu
closely related english languages in
india that provided english so many
important words i mean racist tropes
this took me a long time though
i went um i want actually full props for
my ability to google
this phrase list of hindi or urdu words
in english
and for clicking on the wikipedia
article that popped up at the top of the
list so here we go
here are some other words that must be
highly racialized given her
analysis of why loot is highly
racialized avatar
bandana bungalow cheetah
cot juggernaut jungle
pundit pajamas shampoo
typhoon and veranda
so that's sorry guys those
like frankly the vast vast vast majority
of words in english are now racialized
and you should be really careful using
them
um they're all racist we don't have to
stop there of course i think we have to
abandon all words that aren't uh
indo-european or maybe germanic in
origin
algebra certainly that's from the arabic
in fact man english has a lot of words
from the arabic let's just take
a few that begin with c just c candy
caravan
chemistry cipher from which decipher
comes coffee
cotton crimson they're all racialized
all of them all right now i think i know
where this goes
right the words are racialized
that's bad so bad we shouldn't use words
right which would leave us in silence
which
is violence which is good because
rioting is good because it redistributes
goods in a fair way
did i get it yes if she floats she's a
[Laughter]
[Music]
witch
[Music]
you